Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Hace un tiempo, mientras
caminaba para la escuela,
me pasó algo desagradable.
Para no entrar en detalles
y porque, la verdad,
básicamente no es nada que
no le pase a la mayoría de las mujeres,
un tipo se sintió con la total libertad
de mostrarme su miembro
pensando que tal vez era una buena idea.
En ese momento me asusté,
pero también le grité
"¿Pero qué carajo hacés pelotudo?"
(Aplausos)
Y caminé rápido la cuadra que me faltaba.
Ya en el aula me senté
y le conté a una compañera.
Me preguntó si estaba bien
y quedó todo ahí
porque aunque me estuviese
muriendo de bronca,
¿qué más podía hacer?
Nada.
La realidad es que comparándolo
con cosas que le pasaron a mis amigas,
como que te quieran subir a un auto
y tener que correr para escaparte
o que te manoseen en la calle,
lo que me había pasado a mí
era relativamente insignificante.
Por suerte.
Pero fue suficiente como para
volverme un poco "paranoica"
y hacer que me pareciera una buena idea
empezar a andar por la calle
con un cutter, por las dudas.
El acoso, entre tantos otros temas,
era eso que pasaba y que todo
el mundo sabía que pasaba.
Estaba ahí.
Pero de lo que por ahí no se hablaba
o se le restaba importancia.
Hoy en día, sin embargo,
tanto este tema como otras cuestiones
tienen una mayor visibilidad.
En parte, porque hay cosas
que ya no se aceptan.
Como si antes sí las hubiésemos aceptado.
Pero sobre todo porque las jóvenes,
y los jóvenes en general,
contamos con un espacio donde
podemos manifestar lo que nos pasa.
Tomar la palabra y generar
de alguna manera difusión.
Y lo que es todavía más importante,
apoyo, reacción y organización.
Si lo pensamos, en las redes
estamos participando todo el tiempo.
Le doy me gusta a la foto
que subió un amigo,
voto en la encuesta que hace
alguien que sigo en Instagram
y que por ahí ni conozco.
Doy mi opinión acerca de una noticia
que publicó un medio en Twitter.
Tenemos una herramienta para expresarnos,
para informarnos y construir
nuestras opiniones
acerca de las cosas que pasan,
para manifestar
nuestras reivindicaciones.
Reivindicaciones que, tarde o temprano,
exceden ese espacio y terminan
en una calle o en una plaza.
El año pasado, por ejemplo,
en Berazategui donde vivo,
un par de pibas convocaron
una movilización.
Lo hicieron por numerosos testimonios
que se habían viralizado en redes
de chicas que eran de la zona
y que habían pasado situaciones
bastante feas.
Desde acoso hasta violencia o abuso.
Así fue como un sábado,
a eso de las cuatro de la tarde,
nos juntamos cientos de mujeres
en la plaza.
Yo fui para apoyar.
Fui por mí, porque me pasa.
Pero también fui como una manera
de decirles a todas esas chicas
que se habían expuesto,
contando lo que habían vivido,
que les creía, que no estaban solas.
Y es re loco pensar
que durante mi infancia,
los programas que mirábamos todas,
las letras de sus canciones,
hablaban siempre
de una especie de enemistad
o competencia entre mujeres.
"Nadie pasa de esta esquina,
aquí mandan las divinas.
Fuera feas, fuera feas,
para Uds. no hay lugar".
Pero ¿en qué estaban pensando?
Con los ojos de hoy, la verdad es que
esta letra me parece un poco horrible.
Con todo esto me di cuenta
de que había cosas
que por mucho tiempo
se habían entendido como privadas.
Pero que ahora irrumpían
en el espacio público
y que, al hacerlo, abrían la posibilidad
de generar un cambio.
Me gusta mi generación.
Me gusta porque creo que entendimos
que movernos es la única forma
de potenciar ese cambio.
Poniendo sobre la mesa lo que nos pasa,
lo que no nos gusta.
Y diciendo
"Mirá, esto hay que discutirlo".
Acá hay que hacer algo.
Lo que me pasó a mí yendo al colegio,
quizás no se pueda evitar,
pero por lo menos ahora sé
que hay algo que puedo hacer.
Ya sea por temas de acoso,
cambio climático o cualquier otro,
somos un montón los y las jóvenes
dispuestos a usar las redes
para darle visibilización
a lo que queremos decir.
Pero solo para después
poner el cuerpo y accionar
porque creo que esa es la única forma
de hacernos ver e instalar el debate.
Hoy, tejer esas redes de contacto
con un otro que piensa parecido o no,
que está igual de indignado
y que está dispuesto
a hacer algo o a discutir,
es un poco más fácil.
La sociedad está cambiando.
Cosas que antes mirábamos con recelo
al menos hoy estamos dispuestos
a sacarlas del cajón en el que
estuvieron por mucho tiempo,
para mostrarlas y para discutirlas.
Y aunque quizás todavía
falte mucho por hacer
ojalá que en un futuro ni a mí ni a nadie
nos parezca que es una buena idea tener
que salir a la calle con un cutter.
Pero sí tener que salir a la calle
para luchar por lo que creemos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)